♪♪
You made dinner.
Wait, what is that?
-Hotdogs and macaroni.
Perfect. No notes.
Cole:
We'll need music and
choreography.
Bitsy:
Shake it, Helen.
Yep, it's really great.
Oh, we'll see about that.
♪♪
Bitsy:
When they find out what I've got
cooking,
Bitsy:
they're gonna line up at
Bitsy's soup-kitchen for a handout
and I'll say. "Get away from my
soup, it's made for me" (Giggle)
Now I want soup.
♪♪
With these plans I'll be able to
buy Central Park.
Wanna see? There you go, to
fast? here, take another look.
Oh, too quick? Didn't see it?
So sad.
♪Central Park♪
♪♪
Is this a judged competition?
With points for style, points
for required movements
and points for that extra
undefinable something?
Time to let my hair down.
Guess this is just the shape my
hair is now.
A squirrel just nibbled on my
toe.
Mom advise, what's mom advise?
Really good advise, given for
free?
We hit the mother-load.
Scooch over, I'm getting in.
Please don't be naked.
(Blowing raspberry)
Put drinkie in mouthy.
♪Back In Central Park♪
I'm freaking out.
The lies will drown this family
We're the best family ever,
remember?
And we're having fun! Say it!
Uh, we're having fun.
-Good.
♪Central Park♪